the president of the eu razor group is
with me here um ian bremer
what was it like today i mean russia
isn't here but we seem to have been
talking an awful lot about russia
haven't we yeah i mean look i obviously
be better for every one of the russians
we're here because
this organization needs to engage
uh it was 2009 i think was the last time
right that you haven't had a russian
delegation the meeting security
conference it's a truly dangerous
situation we are closer to major power
conflict than at any point since
really this the cold war um and uh
the the flip side of that
is that you remember the last time we
were here together it was two years ago
yeah the theme was restlessness yes oh
there's a lot of there's a lot of
wastefulness going on here right because
nato feels more relevant it feels more
aligned it feels more coherent it feels
a lot more scared too they have a
mission they're worried once again about
russian escalation and what it means if
a fundamental norm of ukrainian
sovereignty and self-determination gets
overthrown not just eroded but
overthrown now russia was citing
scheduling issues for not being here but
clearly they were trying to make a point
do you think they managed to get a point
across or have they missed out on an
opportunity
i i think it's an opportunity they're
not interested in i think what we've
seen over the last 48 hours has been
consistent escalation from the russians
i mean in the security council yesterday
we had
the russian government saying that
ukrainians were exterminating russians
in the occupied territories of the
donbass
definably false and today genocide is a
word putin also putin used that word
with the german chancellor olav schultz
earlier this week and now you see the
leaders of the separatist territories
calling for an evacuation of all
russians living there to go to russia
and we're seeing more troops being sent
to the region
directly opposed to what the russians
say are going on so every actual not
what they're saying but their messages
on the ground are consistently towards
we are going to take effort i'll tell
you the one thing that worried me the
most was when the ukrainian kindergarten
was hit yeah because you know all of the
shelling and if they had killed kids
how do you just sit there as the
ukrainians how do you not respond in
other words the russians took an act
that had the potential to trip directly
into military conflict that was a risk
they were prepared to take i don't think
we can say this is purely about coercive
diplomacy and maybe he's bluffing
anymore i think the willingness of the
russians to take military action is very
much on display is that something that
was underestimated i mean i was also
speaking to some people here who are
saying
you know we don't know what we're in for
yet here they will try and find a way to
get the ukrainians to provoke them to
find a reason in there so have have
leaders been too naive in the west
particularly in europe look i think
there are two things the russians really
want to do here one is they want to find
a way to divide nato and so far they
failed at that and two they want to find
a way to provoke the ukrainians and so
far they've failed at that as well but
they're not done they're not going to
make this easy
on the west i mean you know we see how
united nato is today there's nothing
that would unite nato more than a full
russian invasion into ukraine
overthrowing president zielenski they're
not going to do that they're going to
take incremental steps and they're going
to look for more opportunities for the
west to make mistakes
look for more opportunities to see any
potential division that erodes any
weakness that might come from the
ukrainian president and exploit it
that's what they're trying to do now
we've all learned where luhansk and
donetsk is on the map but talking to
baltic leaders in particular when really
gets a sense that this is about a lot
more than ukraine
what's really at stake here for europe
well the estonian former estonian
president has been here uh kirsten
castrolaj she's been extremely
articulate talking about the fact that a
lot of western norms have already been
eroded who responded when the russians
were engaged in disinformation
against the american elections or
against the european elections or
against brexit who responded when the
russians engaged in the not pecha cyber
attacks against ukraine that also led to
billions of dollars of damage to western
multinationals operating globally like
maersk and fedex europe who responded
when the estonian government her own
estonian government back in 2009 was hit
with these massive cyber attacks from
russia the russians are the ones taking
lessons here not the chinese for taiwan
the russians they've taken lessons over
the last decade that the europe the
europeans and the americans are not
prepared to respond when they act with
impunity and they saw today
an extraordinary opportunity
post-afghanistan with the americans
focusing more on asia with biden as the
new president maybe a little older maybe
a little weaker they saw with the brits
with a shamballic government that's
falling apart with the germans after
merkel's already gone transition took
power transition in france to coming up
with the elections
and they saw more influence and leverage
on energy flows downstream in europe
than they've ever had before and then
they'll ever have again and i think that
they took lessons from all of that and
said this is our opportunity and what i
am seeing at the munich security
conference today is finally
this is the moment where the western
alliance is saying no more
we will not tolerate this behavior and
we will take actions that may risk a lot
for everybody but when you hear no more
does it sound exactly in the same tune
we saw a u.s secretary of state lincoln
on stage together with german foreign
minister annalina bierbach and she time
and time again stressed that germany
would be willing to take very painful
action also for the europeans and for
themselves
anthony blinken totally agrees both
sides completely agree but when it
really comes down to defining whether a
hybrid attack
overstepped that red line that and that
u.s president biden also blurred
somewhat by saying there is a difference
between between
his cyber in that press conference and
then ever since so you know are they
really on the same page yeah i want
really oversteps that right now i'm not
saying that they are 100 on the same
page especially as the russians provide
opportunities from them to show that
maybe they're on slightly different
pages slightly different parts of the
same page you know it's a little blurry
the letters that are on that page but i
want to be clear
if any russian troops
go into any ukrainian territory even
territory that has already been occupied
the americans are going to put
significant sanctions on russia and
those sanctions will include
the companies that are involved in
nordstrom 2. that's over those sanctions
will include financial sanctions
technology export restriction sanctions
and individual sanctions against
oligarchs members of putin's family and
the europeans
many of them are going to go along with
that certainly the host german
government here that's meaningful i'm
not suggesting that there won't be
a lot of you know nervousness on the
part of some european governments i'd be
most worried about where french
president macron would be in that
indication for example and if the french
president is a little squishy then
you'll see other governments like spain
certainly hungary cyprus and others hide
behind that position but it is very
clear to the russian government that if
they take the steps that they now look
very likely to take there are
consequences and remember president
putin told his people today
that sanctions are coming severe
sanctions are coming whether there's
anything in ukraine or not he is
preparing his population for that damage
that he appears very very willing to
take now we spent so much time talking
about russia because it's such a
pressing issue but pretty much everyone
here agrees that the overarching issue
of our time is really climate change and
i thought there was a bit of a killer
question actually today by bangladesh
foreign minister saying look is russia
is this going to take funding away from
tackling the challenge for mankind and
anthony blinken the u.s secretary of
state said well no it won't because it's
in the budget but
it might be in this budget does does the
west really have the stomach and the
resources to do both well i mean first
of all if the europeans have gas flows
cut off in the near term that's going to
mean
more fossil fuel you know focus on other
parts of the world but in very short
order that pushes the europeans to
diversify faster and faster towards
renewables so i think it actually moves
you more quickly in that direction no i
don't think the russia situation makes
you pay attention less to climate change
i think the pandemic situation does
because there you have
medium and lower income countries that
have increasingly unsustainable
indebtedness and the west needs to
provide capacity for them to have you
know a green transition that they can
afford there needs to be vastly more
money given to lower income countries so
they can actually make a transition as
opposed to make the arguments that we
need to have our opportunity to dump
more carbon into the atmosphere because
we haven't had that chance yet i'm much
more worried about the pandemic from
that perspective there's a lot of talk
in germany of rise and also near rise
and energy prices it's coming people
yeah people really feeling the pressure
so from the conversations you've had do
you think that um
leaders are ready to really break it to
their public as well that that taking
responsibility for the development in
other countries making them co2 neutral
leapfrogging uh the whole carbon stage
we're not there we're not where we need
to be there's an enormous amount of um
momentum
towards uh renewable energy including
nuclear energy as we're seeing from
france's president macron which i
consider to be a positive thing but
that's very different from spending on
other countries around the world that's
a real gap we've seen that gap in terms
of the pandemic we've seen that gap in
vaccines we've seen that gap in terms of
health funding we're going to see that
gap more and more on climate change as
well that's a big problem so what are
your highlights at this unique security
conference kamala harris is there the
u.s vice president do you think that's
more flagship what do you expect to hear
from her very little um you know
president biden loves this meeting he's
been here many many times if he could be
here right now he would be here right
now he can't if you don't send biden and
you only send a cabinet secretary that
shows that you don't really value this
conference as highly so i mean kamala
harris is not being sent because she has
a portfolio on europe or in russia
ukraine she's not a principal she's not
a decision maker on any of those issues
happening right now that's biden that's
tony blinken that's jake sullivan and
increasingly as it becomes military
that's also the secretary of defense
it's the head of the cia
but it's not kamala she's here because
this is a very important conference and
president biden wants to make that clear
and what are the key issues i mean that
we have we have plenty of crises around
the world the style region seems to be
increasingly destabilized um
particularly with mali french potent now
pulling their troops out so um what are
the conversations you're planning on
here what's what to listen out for us i
mean the conversations are that it's not
just about ukraine there are a lot of
conflicts out there that are bursting
out because the united states doesn't
consider it a top order priority and no
one is prepared to remotely sit into the
shoes that the americans have
historically filled americans pull out
of afghanistan russians aren't going and
chinese aren't going in afghanistan is
on the verge of collapse and we're
looking at millions of refugees that
could be coming even myanmar which
china's utterly critical for but the
fact is we're more than a year past the
coup and all we've seen is more death
and destruction
haiti america's backyard i mean a
criminal regime in place right now and
the americans are sending refugees back
but they're not doing very much on the
ground in haiti and the sahel well
president macron who talks about
strategic autonomy now has his own
afghanistan okay it's smaller but france
is smaller the fact is that this is not
credible as a policy and so i mean i
think what we have to believe in is that
the alliance is still credible we have
to believe the alliance is still
resilient and that is certainly the
message we're hearing right now whether
we're hearing it in three months and six
months time is an interesting question
just one final question so how closely
is china watching how the west is
dealing with ukraine and russia they're
watching it very closely but not because
they're planning on invading taiwan
they're watching it closely because they
want to understand if it turns out that
we have a military confrontation how do
they ensure that the americans and the
europeans aren't suddenly together
against china too they don't want that i
think it was very interesting that xi
jinping took that phone call with macron
and afterwards gave a readout that
called for a lot more stability than
anything you heard from president putin
all right well thank you so much for
your assessment as always in grammar
from your razor group and we'll keep the
conversation going thanks so much
you